I actually okay this is I'm a fan are
you guys a fan of Kelly obviously I'm a
I'm a big fan I go in these youtube
dumpster dives where I just like to
watch compilation videos of voice and
but I only want to see the ones that are
chosen because it makes me too sad to
see the ones that are rejected
you should be there when it oh okay they
say I got a lot of questions I get a lot
of questions but I my favorite thing is
when you guys turn around and you have
that reaction of who it is because I
love that you only hear their voice I
have seen every season every compilation
video the best is seeing the parents in
the back to react when you guys turn
around
that is just immediate joy I just I
can't get enough of it
any of those kind of competition yeah so
you're a music lover then I love I love
oh we have something in common
you know oh yeah if you don't you're
welcome the most amazing singer voice
much like yours no yeah much like yours
is just completely pure at that mountain
song which you covered which I saw on
YouTube it's just she just has an
organic quality to her songs and I've
what now I'm turning into a real crazy
person you know there was a YouTube when
you were doing a performance I can't and
so trying to get to tell you this
you were doing a performance in the UK
and you had a gold shimmery dress on
and a black belt and there's a marching
band from one and you were singing mr.
know-it-all
I have played that I'm all those views
that that dress is so tight I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this